[Music]
this Sunday you'll be in for a different
kind of federal Justin Timberlake's
halftime performance and as we've seen
as in Super Bowls past there is always
that one shocking moment just last year
gaga made a spectacular arrival
suspended from the stadium roof how
excited he would be doing Super Bowl
it's amazingly overwhelming Katy Perry
had the most-watched halftime show ever
over 118 million viewers in 2015 in 2013
beyoncé's performance marked her
long-awaited reunion with Destiny's
Child but they only sang one of these
solo hits
[Applause]
it feels good to know that the hard work
paid off the biggest show in America and
there's so many things that could happen
being God was on my side great time
great crowd great crowd ready Ben it's a
great occasion it's great piece of
Americana
incredibly for the first twenty four
years
the halftime show was mainly marching
bands and the review up with people but
when competing Network started
counter-programming the game the
halftime show shifted to a list pop
stars it was Michael Jackson in 93 in
2001 Britney Spears took the stage along
with then boyfriend Justin Timberlake
and NSYNC see weeks ago they called me
up and asked me and I was like yes Diana
Ross headlined in 96 her most memorable
moment was her exit by helicopter
[Music]
Bruno Mars's appeared twice first
headlining in 2014 and then joining
Beyonce and her third appearance in 2016
they performed with Coldplay
how do you top this feeling I don't
[Music]